[Music]
foreign
amir thank you for joining me on 20
minute leaders
thank you for having me how are you good
how are you doing so great to have you
here california
you know so far it's not too bad i'm
having a good time here
in southern california but you know it's
a shelter in place in the bay area and
it's
all remote so you know i'm just keeping
in mind that so many millions of people
are losing their jobs and you know it's
just a very difficult situation that
i think that we're fortunate to still be
working and to still be active and doing
our thing
and you're in upstate new york right
you're away from all the
all the troubles yeah
we took a house in upstate for a couple
of weeks and um
yeah and i think like um in a week or
two we'll be back
uh to the city not a lot to do there at
the moment you know apart from staying
at home and uh
once a week go to the supermarket
definitely
so when this airs you'll probably be
back in the city already and everything
will be fine
so we'll also we'll assume that right
now everything's okay
hey amir you a we got to meet a few
months ago when i
came to visit this incredible place
called show fields in new york
and i walk in and it seems like a
regular store but it's called the
the most interesting store in the world
that's the sign of the front
and my friends came and showed me this
incredible place and then they said oh
yeah and
it's run by israelis and and amir here
is
he's actually one of the co-founders of
this why was i so amazed
tell me what is show fields and how did
you
come to do this um
well okay where do i start around three
years ago
we we kind of like recognized the gap
between
the fact that we live in this unique
point of time in which there is more
innovation more cool brands out there
than
probably any other point of time in
history
um and the fact that when you walk the
streets of
new york london berlin tel aviv hong
kong it all looks the same and none of
these streets have all these like
beautiful variety of brands um and that
gap
is that like that observation is what
started our journey
along the way we found out that the
reason for this gap is
because while it's very easy to start
your business online
so it is easy used to succeed online but
it's still relatively easy to start
the barriers strengthened to the
physical world are
actually really really really high and
most of the brands in the world
they don't have the skill set needed in
order to open their own physical store
um what we thought about is that if we
can make the process of
opening your own physical store to be as
easy as it is to open a website
we can then solve a huge problem for
this huge variety of online brands
and while solving their problem and
allowing them easy access to prime
location physical retail
we can actually solve the problem that
that we really set ourselves to solve
which is solving for the discovery
problem in the physical world uh
bringing back the sense of discovery to
the physical world
uh why is this so challenging so why why
is it difficult for a company to say
okay we have a new brand we have a new
line of products let's say baby clothing
why is it difficult for me to now go and
get a store in new york and just
start selling my baby clothing that way
um so first of all most of the
first-year cities in the u.s have mostly
very large spaces in prime locations so
you
it would be very hard for you to find a
space that fits your needs
second you would have to sign on a
long-term commitment which is something
that even
brands who do dozens of millions of
dollars in sales annually cannot even
contemplate
and only then you can start like
building the space designing it hiring
the stuff
operate it all these brands that know
how to analyze data online and how to
acquire customers online
um and how to run a successful econ
business
do not necessarily have the skill set to
do real estate
um and so uh we're left with the
situation where like 95 percent of the
brands in doing well today cannot even
consider prime location physical retail
um and and and the loss is
uh you know for the consumers that like
don't get to experience these brands in
the physical world
our vision is to empower all customers
to be
inspired engaged and connected when
experiencing these brands um and and you
know
since the last time we spoke um
like if you around like you don't know
what show feeds is
um has even um you know became wider
um and i mean that like when we look at
show fields now we see it as a space
that merges art and retail
right like you have show and fields show
is the part of the art and the
experiences etc
and fields is the commerce part um and
this can be in many
of many shapes of forms right shapes and
forms
can be in 11 bond street in new york it
can be in 530 lincoln and road which is
our space in miami
and it can be through our econ platform
that we just launched a week and a half
ago ah
okay speak about that actually if you
want to hear more
uh because like it's something that
we're really really excited about um
and you know for some people uh it may
look like
very quickly put it together to you know
double down ecom like what we
discovered situation and but it's
actually some
working on like for more than a year wow
um
a great tech team is working on that and
we're able to launch it um in a very
you know interesting thing um
so amir right before we get to there
because i want you to paint the picture
for somebody who's who i'm very
fortunate that i got to experience show
fields but you know many don't because
it's in new york and it's in miami and
but it's such a unique experience that i
i really want to try and capture the
essence of it so walk me through as i
as i walk through the door what do i
experience over there
so in new york we have a four-story
building which is
uh located on the corner of bonded
lafayette street
um basically half of the space is
dedicated to
show which is a food and beverage
component
with a place where people can hang which
includes an
entire top floor which is only dedicated
to empower these brands and like
constantly hosting different
events and activations um and
changing art exhibitions etc so all
these are the show areas the other 50
are the fields which is basically our
product um each field is like a room
when you step inside this room it's an
immersive
holistic very elegant experience around
a certain brand
so basically you walk the space you
get inspired by art which is constantly
rotating and changing
and every time you decide to step from
the show areas to one of the fields it's
all about the brands it's not about us
anymore
uh so it's a space for discovery you
walk in and you don't know
what you're gonna find even if you
visited the store a month ago
because we keep it fresh the entire time
and i mean both the show part
and the fields part fields basically
change every
six months so every six months we have a
very big pr moment where we launch
a new curation of brands uh this moment
uh
by the way was supposed to take place on
march 27th
uh so this hitted us um
you know in a very interesting timing um
but um you know when we're going to
reopen the store it's still going to be
the march curation because these brands
are basically
uh supposed to activate their spaces
until the end of september
and then we launched the holiday season
curation
so there is a slide going in between the
floors there is as i said an entire
floor with a huge terrace
that um you know every brand the joints
show will get to host
up to two events a longer term um in
this space without any additional cost
and we initiated
around 200 events last year on in this
law from
movie nights to panels to
you know the global form of the
management of lvmh to
dinner for influencers michelin chefs
dinners
um art workshops et cetera et cetera so
so amir i mean two things that are very
interesting one is
that you're actually when you go to the
store you actually you can buy the
product so it's not just
you know a marketing scheme where you
can walk in and be amazed with a brand
and then you go on amazon and buy
there's actually sales people
who are trained on the brand
and they can and you can swipe your
credit card on the spot and just get the
get whatever you just used so i remember
walking in and there was
there was this chemist who was showing
me how he's making these potions from
you know these powders these drinks and
after i tried one i could just purchase
it and take it home which which i think
is just
you know it's a great experience that
you know as an avid e-commerce
a consumer all of a sudden being able to
have a similar experience but in the
physical world
was very monumental for me but i think
what's even more interesting from a
business perspective and that's how i'm
approaching this right now
is your ability to have this seamless
onboarding
where every six months you get to curate
new
new brands in new spaces how do i mean
it
and this is really where the magic
happens right because it's usually so
difficult
for a for a brand to open up a store and
you're able to do it
almost with minimal contact with the
brand right and all of a sudden they
have a pop-up shop
yeah you know like when you think about
the technology involved
in show fields uh which is you know
basically involving everything we do
um the two most interesting parts are
one the onboarding process
as you've said uh which is a very
seamless six steps process
all line basically you don't have to
step
you know in new york in order in a store
um in our space
um and it's something that we've been
working on for more than two years
building this platform and allowing
brands to do it and
that's crazy allowing somebody to open
up a store without ever
visiting that store it's it's
mind-blowing
really thank you um i'm really impressed
yeah
it's not easy at all the only part by
the way which isn't
done um you know entirely automatically
is the design process which is obviously
taken care of by us uh but there are
like a couple of
like design rounds where like we allow
the brand to like
you know direct us in the right
direction until we can lock a design
that is agreed upon both parts
but then we take care of the entire like
fabrication installation to build out
everything is done
um and by the way until today it was
done overnight so basically you don't
have any like
dead time in store um
yeah um you know i'm probably not the
best person about
like to dive in really deeply into the
show fields technology
because like that's not the part that
i'm dealing with on a daily
basis i'm more like leaving our um
revenue targets and uh real estate
so talk to me about the future talk to
me about what's happening
in real estate e-commerce the mixture
as you're looking you know business-wise
into the
next few years i'm still trying to
figure out so
uh you know every day uh but there are a
lot of thoughts right like
um thinking about the retail real estate
market
yeah we like unrelated to covet was the
most distressed
market in the us for like three four
years um
i think like it got like the last push
like that he needed to
fall from the cliff now covey did it um
and i think that um
i don't think there was any other point
of time in history
in which the retail market in the us was
more
of a tenant market just because there
are no tenants
out there and the vacancy rates are like
skyrocketing
um you walk on fifth avenue and
literally fifth avenue is for rent
um it's insane uh where is everybody
going by the way
where did everybody go closing stores
because
they're out of business yeah um you see
um you know it's a different
conversation about like what happened to
the retail market and why are these
vacancies and like the common
misconception is because like
augment okay e-commerce one and then
like you know
no more physical retail um which is like
very not correct because what really
happened is that like from the one hand
you had
all these dinosaurs who couldn't adopt
well to the digital age
and closed hundreds of stores especially
a lot of them signed on these leases
like 25
years ago and now these leases end and
when they want to renew
with the fair market value it just
doesn't make sense anymore
um and and on the other side you see all
these digital native brands who want
their subcategory
online opening hundreds of stores like
casper um and glossier
and away et cetera et cetera
and in the middle the most important
thing that happened is basically
that like first of all big box retail
like
uh really weakened because transactional
shopping went
dramatically online um we're not
interested anymore in going downstairs
to buy toilet paper like i can tell i
like to
bring it to my house um and
and more than all the zoning authorities
in the u.s allowed to build
way too much retail and as a real estate
developer i can
tell you that like when the government
allows or when the zoning
laws law allows for real estate
developers to build retail
they do because historically generates
four to six times more than office and
residential
and they just allowed too much and we
came to a point in which
in any other place in the world other
than the us you have between seven to
nine square foot retail per capita
in the u.s you have 27. so
what would happen in my opinion and
that's unrelated to kovid is that a lot
of the retail in the suburbs is going to
disappear
companies are going to eliminate lines
from their balance sheet and just
convert it to residential
uh office or logistics which is by the
way if you look for one
uh retail stock market that would
definitely strengthen like significantly
as a result of coffee
which by the way was was strengthening
unrelated to that
is logistics um so that's interesting
um i don't know what would happen with
office i'm hearing like
you know stuff or like different
directions
a lot of companies suddenly found out
that like a big chunk of their employees
can like work very well from home
and and maybe they don't need like these
huge offices
um i don't know what it will do to the
flexible office
market um maybe it's positive for them
in the short term
obviously it's a disaster i don't know
like which company will survive that or
not
um but it's definitely
um interesting time yeah i'm here so
with all this in mind you're launching a
new e-commerce
platform for show fields i don't know
about it yet so tell me what what is
this
um so again it's a space that merges art
and retail
um in order to empower and engage and
and inspire consumers
and the way we do that in our ecom is
basically by launching
new curations constantly of very very
highly curated
d2c brands by the way it's the first
time that you're going to have
um an online environment for multi
d2c brands that is highly curated only
for d2c brands
which is like sounds stupid but like
it's innovative even in that regard
so what does that mean highly you know
experiential why is that why is this
different from going on walmart or
amazon
where i see sometimes the similar brands
so basically what we do is we we use
influencers
as amplifiers for these curations so
whenever i launch a new creation
currently it's like twice a week
soon it's going to be maybe every day um
a certain influencer who by the way
picked the product that he liked
from like a variety of products that we
gave them um
is uploading a live video um
in which they go over like each one of
these products and show how they use it
and why they like it
and tell the audience about it um and
while you watch the video you can also
like very seamlessly buy the products
because
um you know you have this like small
pop-up on top of the video that you can
press and then
directly buy it and obviously the entire
products are later on in
on our website right and this influencer
is inviting like their entire followers
to watch that
uh way more engaged
you know audience and our assumption is
that like a person that buys a quick
toothbrush
is more likely to buy also a swell
bottle right and if this assumption is
correct
we're gonna see like multi purchases if
we're going to see multi purchases
we'll probably be able to provide these
direct to consumer brands with the lower
cac
if we can provide them with the lower
cat that's it like we want again
yeah and you know how to you know bundle
these things together and which
brands to curate it with which others of
the same week
and and yeah no that's it's that's a
fascinating world amir our 20 minutes
are almost over it went
one it went by way too quickly i'm going
to put you on the spot
uh one last time i'd like you to tell me
three words that you think would best
describe you
or if i ask anybody in show fields how
would they describe
amir in three words
um
hard working is like a word yeah yeah
definitely
so i would say hard-working as a result
of that i would also say tired because
like
that's like the hard-working and the
one-year-old
and the fact that you woke up at 5am
today and drove
an hour to get medic medicine yeah i'm
in the 5am club but not voluntarily
love it yeah and um
i don't know like i guess like uh
maybe we'll leave this question to them
i don't know i'd go with innovative just
because i
you know i went to show fields and i was
i was
taken a good friend of mine paul from
new york
that he's one of the most innovative
guys that i know he took me to show
fields because they said michael i want
you to see what's happening here
i didn't know that it's run by israelis
i didn't know you back then
and i was just amazed i felt like i was
in a walking website
and it felt so so cool and we didn't
even talk about you know the analytics
that you're doing
and all these sorts of things incredible
amir thank you so much for the time
like i wish i could you know own this
entire like um
innovation but like to myself but
obviously like
uh this is like a vision of like my
partners as well and
um and and this the entire team of show
fields
of course i i can't wait to see where
this is going to go and i can't wait to
come visit also the miami
and the miami branch sounds good all
right thank you
we'll be there bye thank you